[Musique]
même le sexe écoute bien aces high techs
j'ai toujours su ce qui allait se passer
donc j'ai un peu été déçu par l'amour
elle disposait d'un type de voyance
munich
elle savait s'y prendre avec les hommes
bonjour j'habite à l'étagé du dessous
mais voilà désolé c'était en cas de
souci
[Musique]
il est en train de tomber amoureux en
général avec moi sa fille
[Musique]
parce que j'ai créée j'ai peur que les
critiques ne perçoivent que comme un
fantasme masculin
j'essaie thème contre-garde j'adore
qu'on me regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donne moi la jalousie
reviens sket dance m
or que je vais débuter pour sa 8 heures
ça va
[Musique]